I've become borderline obsessed with generative AI chatbots like chatGPT.
And it seems I'm not the only one!
Everyone's talking about them! But while generative AI chatbots are the current hot topic,
another form of chatbot-- rule-based chatbots have been around for years.
So, what's the difference?
Do they work in the same way, or has generative AI chatbots made role-based chatbots obsolete?
Let's take a look.
So let's begin with a few definitions.
Generative AI chatbots utilize LLMs, or large language models,
to generate responses based on user inputs. And they are trained on a massive datasets containing billions of words, phrases and sentences.
And these models leverage deep learning models, neural networks, and also natural language processing.
And these help the chatbot understand and produce human-like responses.
Now on the other hand, rule-based chatbots adhere to a collection of pre-determined rules.
So the very much rules engine based.
And they use these rules for producing replies for the user inputs.
Now they utilize a sequence of if/then statements to verify the presence of specific keywords that are sent into the chatbot.
And those are then used-- and understanding these as inputs --to deliver corresponding responses based on those conditions.
Now, the architecture of rule-based chatbots-- we can think of it in like three high-level components that are all interconnected.
So what have we got here?
We've got the user interface, or the UI.
We've got the NLP engine.
And we've also got another engine, the rules engine.
And here the UI, this is where the users interact with the chatbot,
and NLP engine processes the inputs, and then the rules engine determines the appropriate response.
And in some are rule-based chat bots, "NLP engine" maybe overselling a little bit what this component doesbecause some simpler
rule-based chat bots might rely only on keyword detection without utilizing full NLP techniques. But this is the basic idea.
So let's ask a rule-based chatbot a question: What are the operating hours of the electronic store?
Now the chatbot would derive a conditional statement that detects entities such as "operating hours" and "electronics store".
And then based on these predetermined entities and context,
the chatbot can determine the user's intents and generate a predefined response, like "the electronic store operates from 9 a.m. to 7 p.m.".
Now at a high level, the architecture for a generative AI chatbot, well, it doesn't look so different.
We can think of it also in three high level components.
So at the top, again, we have the UI, or the user interface.
We also again have an NLP engine.
And now here, instead of the rules engine, we have a large language model, an LLM.
But if you look between or beneath the surfaces here, there are some fundamental differences between these two.
Now the NLP engine in a rules-based chatbot extracts intent entities and context [as] we said,
but the NLP engine here, combined with the large language model in a generative AI chatbot,
can handle much more complex language structures and nuances.
It can better understand the user's inputs, context and intent.
And large language models do not rely on pre-written rules, but they have been trained on vast amounts of text data which
allows the chatbot to generate contextually relevant and humanlike responses.
One of the significant advantages of generative AI chatbots is their ability to learn and adapt over time
by continually updating their knowledge and refining that language model,
these chat bots can provide more accurate and relevant responses.
So, does this spell the end for rule-based chatbots?
Are generative AI chatbots always the better option?
Well, the answer to that depends, as ever, on your use cases.
So let's briefly consider a couple.
First of all, let's consider frequently asked questions and customer support--so that sort of scenario.
Now, in this sort of scenario where we have user queries that are relatively simple,
relatively predictable, a rule-based chatbot can be an efficient and cost effective solution.
For instance, in the context of a customer support scenario for an online store, a rules-based chatbot can quickly provide answers
to frequently asked questions about shipping or returns or product information--stuff like that.
Now, for sure, a generative AI chatbot could fulfill this use case too,
but this could lead to increased complexity and cost without a significant improvement in performance.
Or actually, if we're not careful, it could lead to worse performance as LLMs introduce the potential
for sharing incorrect information through something called hallucinations,
which are instances when the chatbot produces responses that aren't grounded in reality or factual information.
Okay, what about another scenario?
What if we want to consider things that are creative or open ended?
Now, in this sort of situation, we're talking about things like generating story ideas or sort of brainstorming ideas, things like that.
And a generative AI chat bot is the obvious answer here
because of  its advanced language understanding and creative capabilities, it can excel at these tasks.
It can "think outside the box" and generate unique and engaging content or ideas.
Creative writing tasks are my favorite use for this type of chatbot.
Rule-based chatbots are limited by that predefined rules and lack the flexibility to generate innovative, reasoned responses.
Now, for now, in the current times, I think we can say that both chatbots have their place.
Generative AI chatbots are becoming more powerful and may eventually supersede rule-based chatbots in many cases.
But today, generative AI chatbots still have concerns around privacy of training data
and a tendency to sometimes produce output that is misleading or incorrect.
But look, this is an exciting time in the chatbot space.
And I hope you share just a little bit of my obsessive interest in where this journey will take us.